[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
so marius
at last i find you
tyrio
yes
they're always watching i've been
searching for you for a long time malius
i was rather beginning to think you
didn't want to be found
oh forgive me tyrion please
it
it wasn't my fault
not your fault tell me malice how was it
not your fault
the wanderer
yes
it was
was the wanderer
my days in the rogue citadel seemed so
long ago
i sought refuge
from my memories in the company of other
outcasts
high in the mountains past the eastern
gate
[Music]
oh i fought sleep
for days at a time
for when i dreamt
the memories
would
return memories of the monastery
and the evil
which it claimed
three memories
i couldn't tell the difference anymore
and the evil from my dreams
followed me at my heels
how had he found me here
look at this broken shell of a man
barely able to carry the weight of his
own spawn
be the burning terror
which drove me to hide here
he seemed
to have demons of his own
he struggled to contain
was losing
[Music]
as i watched
i became convinced
that i was truly mad
the terror
the destruction leader the evil i
witnessed
how else could i explain them
were these the demons from my dream
were they born
within the wonder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
why did i follow him
i don't know
why do things happen as they do in
dreams
all i know is that when he beckoned
i had to follow him
but from that moment
we traveled together east
always
into the east
[Music]
we traveled east
over the mountains and into the vast
deserts of broken lands
[Music]
as the days passed my companion told me
of himself
that he had once been a great warrior
and that a dark and secret burden
now
weighed heavily upon him
we traveled for an eternity across that
aran wasteland how long
i couldn't say
and always
a dark cloud seemed to follow us
just over the horizon
finally the journey ended we climbed the
last bridge
there below us lay
our destination
the shining jewel grouped cool lane
with a great sea beyond
we made camp that last night
perhaps it was the warm desert wind or
the sound of the ocean but for the first
time in many weeks
i slept however
the dreams returned but these were
clearly not my own i beheld the vision
of a great man the mage tell russia you
were there too tyriel i remember seeing
you in my dream
his brethren had cornered a great demon
a veil of lord of destruction who had
been set loose upon the world
and they attempted to imprison the demon
within a sacred stone
yet whether attempts failed
tarasha selflessly volunteered to
contain the demon within himself
completing the prison
he instructed his brethren to find him
within a tomb
buried under the sand and there to
wrestle with the demon for all eternity
now you know what i seek marius
this is my brother
sleep now
we set out with the dawn
the next morning we walked over the hill
toward
luke colleen
i had no idea then
of the horrors that were in store for me
there
[Music]
my companion drew in the tank cold air
of the tomb
it
seemed to
strengthen him
i stood in the doorway between light and
dark
what was left of my sanity
implored me not to enter
but that voice
was just a whisper now
as we worked our way down deeper and
deeper
i began to see a change in my companion
he seemed to be gaining strength
i can hardly see in the gloom but
my companion
seemed to know the way
we came at last to a great hall
[Applause]
it was then i realized my companion
hadn't been gaining strength he had been
losing
what was left of his humanity
[Music]
shall not be set free not even by you
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no don't do it
[Music]
this day
go to the temple of light in the eastern
city of karats
[Music]
run
[Music]
[Music]
what choice did i have
i ran
[Music]
i did as you told me tyrio
i found the temple of the zakaroom
in the deepest recesses of the temple
i found a dark gathering
my companion the wanderer
talrasha
and a great evil
who could only be the lord of patriot
himself
mufisto
i heard a voice
that like a thousand beetles in my heart
[Applause]
[Music]
shall rise
[Music]
earth
[Music]
the skies shall reign fire and the seas
will be covered as blood
the righteous shall fall before the
wicked and all creation shall travel
before the
girls of hell
but i saw a thing whose god meant for
stands ready
[Applause]
now my young brother the time has come
to assume your true
lord of terror
[Music]
[Music]
you are the hardest
so
[Music]
i heard later that he was defeated
[Music]
and that the swordstone were
destroyed in hell forge
all except
one
i failed
i couldn't do as you asked
i couldn't
enter that gate
forgive me
marius
give me the stone and all is forgiven
give it to me marius
it
take it take it
i'm glad this is finally over terrier
look
what the stone has done
to me
[Applause]
you haven't failed old man
you've done exactly as you were meant to
do however
i am not the archangel tyrion
[Music]
now i think you shall have your
to
rewards
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
out
hey
baal
the gates of zecheron have stood for
eons beyond remembrance
and you shall not breach them now
remove your foul demons from our lambs
we stand on the side of light
you shall not be allowed to reach mount
auread
and that which you seek
will not be yours
i shall take your position
into consideration
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
well
it seems your terms
are not acceptable
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
you